all right here with reaction former
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
author of the bestseller the Geraldo
show Fox News correspondent at-large for
all de Rivera and South Carolina
Republican Governor Henry McMaster is
with us Geraldo let me let me start with
you
because this is really interesting if
you look at the case in particular this
was a first offense lifetime sentence
for a woman who had a lot of personal
problems needed money got involved in
drugs I actually think the case that Kim
Kardashian was pushing was a very
powerful one and when we really need to
pay attention to oh I think there's no
doubt that Kim Kardashian's appearance
at the White House was totally
appropriate I mean Sean Spicer can
answer that a lot better than I but it
just seemed to me that she was really
bringing attention to a very necessary
issue one the White House has now been
grappling with thanks to this new
legislation on sentencing reform and and
so forth a lifetime sentence of no
parole no possibility for all she didn't
murder anybody so I really do think that
Kim Kardashian's visit to the White
House was absolutely appropriate
Samantha bee you know the hypocrisy on
the left I mean we should be outraged by
both Roseanne Barr and Samantha bee and
I think that just very briefly what we
should do is let the victims of their
insults tell us what to do Valerie
Jarrett has responded very graciously to
Roseanne Barr Ivanka Trump has been
beyond gracious when it comes to
Samantha bee maybe you know when they
grovel and they had begged forgiveness
maybe we give forgetting forgiveness
showing I have a Christian view today
what is your take let me show you my
shocked face because I think in both of
these circumstances there's nothing that
that you know it shocks me because one
is the idea that Jim Acosta is deciding
what's an appropriate issue to be
discussed at the White House and just
put the merits of the case aside now I
think Geraldo valiantly displayed what
they are but the bottom line is it's not
up to the media nevermind Jim Acosta to
decide what's a valid issue to be
discussed or not it's up to the
president United States and all other
elected and government of fish
to decide what issues are going to be
addressed the concerns the American
people have and every American has a
right to decide what issues are
important to them and to advocate their
government to support them one way or
the other the idea by the way on the
other piece on Samantha be look I
believe I made a lot of mistakes at the
White House that I asked for forgiveness
for and I think people were very
gracious and in many cases better than
yourself you did not make that many
mistakes I thank you but my point is
this I I think that when people screw up
and they apologize that you give them
forgiveness I think that but the double
standard that exists whether it's
Samantha bee or Joanne Reed or joy joy
read these other people when they make a
mistake the left absolves them and
doesn't you know sort of excuses them
and explains why what they said wasn't
that bad and that there are no
consequences but I agree with her Robin
I mean Bob has been so unbelievably
graceful about this and this isn't the
first time you remember Julia Hoffy the
former political reporter now with the
Atlantic said a very similar thing and
what was the thing then well she didn't
really mean it
so these disgusting and reprehensible
tactics by so-called journalists and
people on the left get excused and
washed away every single time it looked
and and Henry did by the way they look
and you run for a governor down in South
Carolina I was down there recently
beautiful state and I have a lot of
friends down there you know I look at
this and I'm like okay this is now an
environment I've read everybody's
apologies and and I'll give Roseanne I
mean she's apologized again and again
and and I sensed that this real
sincerity here it was a 2:45 a.m. tweet
not a good thing I have my suspicions
well you know what happens to all the
knows a thing very well but what about
the point everybody wants to silence
voices they don't agree with I have
never called for the cancelling of any
show the firing of any host Bill Maher
going back to politically incorrect on
ABC it was people like Sean Hannity and
Rush Limbaugh that said you know what
don't fire them well Sean all these
people are just at
they've just gone crazy President Trump
is enormous ly popular here if he had to
run today to get more votes than he got
when he when he stomped off position the
last time but his tweet was exactly
right he's saying what everybody in
South Carolina's thinking he's a hundred
percent right I just don't know what's
happened to these people on the Left I
don't know if this hatred of the
President or the hatred of what he
stands for which is what America stands
for I think something's something's
happened to these people and they're
making fools of themselves I think
they're so deep in the tank they don't
even realize it and shoot it and they'll
apologize now until the next time and
then the next time and I think the
people just had enough of it but you
know this is a point that I always go
back to as much as I'd like to make
everybody in America watch the show I
have to do a good show and invite them
into in to invite me into my of their
home if you will and and and that's how
you gain an audience and I think the
American people smart and we sell them
short and you know we feel that we have
to silence well in that regard I just
want to say you're referencing something
showing you said at the beginning of
this program this evening about the deep
state coming for you if they come for
you they're gonna have to come through
me because I'm gonna be well I'm gonna
be there you know not the these people
but my bunker I'm safe I don't know I
wonder what's happened to the level of
civility I mean it is so right lowdown
and dirty
now it's a you know the the candidate
for governor in the great state of South
Carolina alluded to it I think that
there has really been a you know we are
that the country is so divided and the
people that hate the president hate him
with such vehemence with such where do
they get this I mean did they do they
really succeed and others that are
really criminals but you don't
understand what he's successful with the
economy look at these numbers he's
successful in North Korea he's six
keeping his promises won't become an
energy independent the biggest tax cuts
that's bad news for Democrats are
although they want to win in 2018 and
for them to win he's got to fail well I
think that that is so desperately
melancholy that they root against their
own country
for partisan purposes you know they get
Sean in for the last word I would just
say the one thing about the Samantha
being thing that troubles me more than
anything is it was pre-taped they
thought about it they script it and they
still went ahead with that's vastly
different than making a really sort of
foot you know stepping in it without
thinking about it I I really think this
case was really different than a lot of
the other ones alright guys good to see
you and Henry McMaster by the way
welcome to the program good-looking you
run down there in South Carolina oh sure
the best